sucedió a las 10 17 del 21 de septiembre
de 2001 comunista escuela secundaria la
confusión se expandió en toulouse ya que
tan sólo 10 días antes habían caído las
torres gemelas pero rápidamente las
autoridades se dieron cuenta de lo que
sucedió la fábrica de fertilizantes a zf
había explotado
no lo sé mira el mercedes mira cómo ha
sido destrozado algo grande le cayó
encima es una pieza de la fábrica el
origen de la explosión fueron cerca de
300 toneladas de nitrato de amonio la
mayoría de los 31 muertos estaban en la
fábrica que quedó reducida a cenizas una
trabajadora temporal
brigitte aubert perdió la consciencia
tras la explosión no expresiones fíjate
y cuando desperté era el apocalipsis la
gente sangraba pedía ayuda había de todo
fresco
21 empleados perdieron la vida en el
lugar y se cambió de puesto con una
compañera aquel día que no sobrevivió
y
este sentimiento de culpabilidad es
fuerte para mí porque para mí murió en
mi lugar y desafortunadamente ese
sentimiento no se va a gestó con el
sonido de las ambulancias de fondo los
residentes de la ciudad buscaban a sus
seres queridos en medio de los daños en
los siguientes 16 años tres casos en los
tribunales barajaron una infinidad de
teorías sobre si había sido un atentado
terrorista o simplemente una explosión
en 2017 condenaron al director de la
fábrica por negligencia pero la
explosión de aspet a efe de toulouse
sigue presente en la ciudad y en la
memoria colectiva del país